[music]
>> Nashville, Music City, where aspiring
artists stake their claim for stardom.
But is that American dream here waking
up to a new reality of corporate
investment, sky-high property taxes, and
a tourist [music] boom? And can the
musicians who once hoped to turn their
struggle into success even afford to
live here anymore?
>> Nashville's always been an affordable
place for musicians to [music] get their
start. Um and I worry that we're losing
that affordability and I find myself
wondering how many [music] how many
Garth Brooks out there are not going to
make it and are not going to come out
and grace us with their music um because
they couldn't come here in the first
place, because they couldn't afford
[music] to be here. I remember when I
first moved here and people would spend
$300 and to crash on their friend's
couch [music] or or room and now we're
talking two, three, four thousand
dollars a month to live.
>> Many locals describe the city's
evolution as a kind of Las
Vegas-ification, a shift towards
spectacle, commercialization, and mass
entertainment at the expense of
authenticity.
>> There were always tourists going to the
honky-tonks on Lower Broad. Tootsie's
was one of the most famous. You know,
we'd go see bands that record labels
wanted to sign,
but you could still get in, you could
still get a a beer for two buck. And
then I would say about 10 years ago it
just exploded where every major artist
has their own honky-tonk and bar. You
can be down there on a Thursday morning
and there's a line. They want you to
come in, get a bucket of beer,
drink it and get out.
>> The drinking came along with the music,
but it was music first. Now, there's
more of a crowd that's here to
>> Just to party.
>> and raise hell.
>> It's a conscious decision of what type
of tourism you get. Authenticity
sells and it and it and it's long-term.
Uh flashy lights and that that's
temporary.
>> Culture here used to be grassroots,
accessible, distinctly local, but that
identity is evolving.
>> the show Nashville, which, you know,
that became not only nationally popular,
but internationally popular, drove this
kind of new wave of of tourism. So, you
have the corporate travel, the
convention travel that was fueled by the
new convention center, and then you have
the individual travel, and, you know,
kind of us shifting to be called the
bachelorette capital of the world.
>> You got to have the tourist dollars, but
there's a way to take in tourism money
and and then reinvest it in the
community.
>> We had about 11 billion in visitor
spending in 2024. It equates to about
$3,600
of revenue that otherwise the citizens
of Nashville would have to cover in
state and local taxes. So,
it really does have a positive impact on
households. It helps us
to fund the services that our community
desperately needs.
>> Many long-term residents are already
struggling to keep up with rising costs
in Trump's America.
The question now is whether Nashville's
identity is still rooted in community or
in capitalism.
Tax is a key issue. Republicans say
Tennessee's low-tax regime has been a
big draw for big companies like Amazon,
Oracle, and Starbucks.
Residents might not have to pay income
tax, but Democrats say this has pushed
revenue-raising into other areas, like
sales taxes and property taxes, and that
has left smaller companies exposed.
>> That's becoming a real issue here in
Nashville, Davidson County, with the
assessments that are skyrocketing. We've
got businesses, constituents, that their
tax bill is quadrupling.
One business downtown, Acme Feed and
Seed right there on First Avenue and
Broadway, their tax bill went from
$129,000
to over $600,000 in 1 [music] year.
>> As property valuations rise, so do
property taxes. And some lease
agreements mean it's the tenants, rather
than the owners, who have to pay up.
>> For business, you need certainty. You've
got to be able to rely on the people
working for you. You need to be able to
have a business plan and work the plan.
You can't overnight increase your taxes
by 400%.
>> Our tax code discriminates against small
businesses. It's really tough in this
environment right now. And a lot of that
hostility has been channeled into
condemning the mayor for increasing
property taxes.
>> The period from 2021 to 2025 just saw a
leap in property values county-wide like
we haven't seen since I can recall.
That's a challenge, and it's the only
way we can operate a city
in the state of Tennessee in the United
States is that
property taxes are the largest portion
of the revenue that we have to keep our
parks and libraries open, to fund our
schools, to fund our police.
>> The construction of the new football
stadium has also raised tensions.
>> They're building a new stadium over
there, you know, a covered dome stadium.
It's It's subsidized by the city.
Oracle's building a big campus over
there. It's subsidized by the city.
Uh
>> Amazon built two towers that are
subsidized
>> by the city.
>> I know there's been tension around the
stadium and and kind of the push and
pull of tourism versus locals, and it's
something we see play out in a number of
a number of places. There's kind of this
tourist versus local that starts to
happen, and I and I want to see it as a
both and, not an either or. We can be
investing in our schools, in our
teachers, and our affordability, but
also building state-of-the-art buildings
that draw people in to help pay some of
those bills.
>> Long-term residents are feeling the
squeeze. Housing costs have doubled
since 2018, largely driven by luxury
high-density developments [music] that
is transforming historic working-class
neighborhoods.
>> Several of our artists in the past 5
years have moved back to their hometowns
just cuz they couldn't afford to live
here anymore, so
>> People are coming to Tennessee because
of the low tax, the low regulation.
There's no state income tax.
>> We are a low-tax state for multinational
corporations and the rich, and we are a
high-tax state for working families. Our
tax code inevitably allows multinational
corporations like FedEx, Amazon, and
Google to muscle their way out of paying
taxes, whereas like small business
owners, including Acme, they are paying
a higher effective tax rate than the
largest companies in this country.
>> They're driving people out while trying
to recruit people left and right to be
in the downtown area. The policies
they're putting in place are pushing
them out.
>> Things that can be done by a city and
community, and an example that we have
actually done here in Nashville is
creating housing that provides
subsidized housing for artists and
musicians.
>> The challenge now is not just sustaining
economic momentum, but making sure the
songwriters, performers, and creatives
who define Nashville's global brand can
continue to live, work, and thrive in
the city they helped put on the map.
>> You know, you can't take these things
for granted. That's what we've learned
over the years is you can't [music] just
assume that Music City brand will be
protected when it's becoming harder and
harder for musicians and artists to live
here.
>> And it's really it is bigger than just
the city. It's really a state, council,
and city problem, and they they have to
get together to create a grander vision
of where we're trying to go and all work
together to execute that vision. The
mayor can't do it on his own, the state
can't do it on their own, council can't
do it on their own.
And there's just been a total lack of
communication or vision in a
how we make sure to to protect this.
>> From honky-tonks to high-rises,
Nashville's evolution tells a story of
growth, opportunity, and unintended
consequences. As the city continues
[music] to expand, the challenge is
clear.
To preserve its cultural identity and
ensure that prosperity [music] is
shared.
Because in Nashville, music isn't just
an industry, it's the foundation of
everything.